[Music]
hi i'm glenn carroll i teach a class at
the stanford graduate school of business
titled leading through culture
i'd like to talk to you about five key
takeaways from this class
[Music]
in traditional management the manager
observes the worker measures his output
coaches him gives him feedback and tells
him how to do it better
in cultural management you build the
system you trust the system and you sit
back and let it happen the hardest times
for a manager in a culturally managed
system is in times of crisis because in
times of crisis the impulse is always to
grab the wheel and to try and direct
things to get in charge
but in a strong culture system you just
have to trust that the system's been
built properly and that things are going
to work out
in his book no rules rules the ceo of
netflix reed hastings tells a story
about how when cheryl sandberg the ceo
of facebook followed him around all day
to see how he managed
at the end of the day he quotes her and
saying the amazing thing was to sit with
you all day long and to see that you
didn't make one decision
reid smiled and said i felt great
because that's exactly what we were
aiming for
the reason he could do this is because
netflix has a strong culture and the
culture has people who are making
decisions very similarly to the way that
reed would have made them himself
but he didn't have to make
the third key takeaway is that you can
build a strong culture around any set of
beliefs values or practices
this is what organizational theorists
call cultural content
and cultural content is irrelevant for
whether you have a strong or weak
culture
don't believe it consider the fact that
i could name examples of strong cultural
organizations from businesses of all
kinds manufacturing
retail service finance you name it
religious cults schools terrorist cells
urban gangs swat teams military special
forces
the content is irrelevant for whether
the culture is strong or weak
[Music]
most managers use three key levers
defining the culture setting up
incentives and launching training
communication programs but in fact there
are something like 20 different levers
that are available for a manager to use
they include things like making the
organization transparent homogenizing
the groupings broadening the job
definitions instituting job rotation
this list of levers is long and can be
used in many different ways
it's a mistake not to use or consider at
least the full set of levers
[Music]
so the fifth key takeaway is about the
most impactful managerial liver it is
culturally selective hiring you can't
always do it you need to be hiring you
probably need to be growing to do it
requires lots of time and interviews
culturally selective hiring is often
criticized today because if it's not
done right it can introduce a lot of
bias and discrimination because when you
select on cultural traits you also get a
lot of other things that are more
homogeneous than you might like the
issue though can be resolved and done
properly
and the important thing to remember is
that culturally selective hiring works
and it is the most impactful thing to
build a strong culture
quickly and effectively
[Music]
[Music]
i always did well in school but i was
also
a little bit of a troublemaker or at
least i hang out i hung out with the
kids who were troublemakers and asked my
my colleagues or my deans you know i i
still cause trouble occasionally you
know in their minds i'm sure
[Music]
you